[Musique]
avec vous Hélène Frat bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline à la une de la presse
donc le franchissement aujourd'hui de la
barre des 8 milliards d'habitants sur la
planète selon l'ONU soit trois fois plus
Hélène que dans les années 50 au coeur
des discussions à la fois de la Coop 27
et du G20 qui se tiennent en ce moment
même le niveau de la population mondiale
a des conséquences à la fois sur
l'environnement et sur notre bien-être
et c'est ce que rappelle la revue
américaine National Geographic qui a
choisi cette photo d'une foule
rassemblée à Bangalore à l'occasion de
la fête de Diwali c'est la fête indou
des lumières pour rappeler vous l'avez
dit que l'Inde s'apprête à dépasser la
Chine à devenir le pays le plus peuplé
au monde où allons-nous à partir d'ici
s'interroge la revue l'augmentation de
la population mondiale interroge et elle
inquiète le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France évoque un vrai défi pour la
planète où l'on compte désormais Pauline
deux humains de plus à chaque seconde
qui passe 8 milliards d'habitants est-ce
humainement vivable le journal salarm de
l'explosion des émissions de CO2 de la
perte de biodiversité et se demande s'il
y aura assez d'espace assez de
combustible d'eau de nourriture pour
tout le monde surtout lorsque la
population mondiale atteindra les 10
milliards d'habitants d'ici la fin de ce
siècle au point que certains se
demandent aujourd'hui s'il faut encore
faire des enfants pour sauver la planète
pour la croix la réponse est non d'après
le journal chrétien opposé population et
climat est un débat
inutile car quelle que soit leur nombre
les Terriens vont d'abord devoir d'abord
et avant tout changer leur mode de vie
pour limiter le réchauffement climatique
et c'est aussi le sentiment du gardien
le quotidien britannique qui lance ce
matin cet appel partagé par une
trentaine de médias à travers le monde à
plante à agir maintenant
le changement climatique est une urgence
globale qui exige la coopération entre
toutes les nations interpellent le
journal en pressant la communauté
internationale de stopper la fuite en
avant qui conduira la planète à un point
de non-retour à un point où le chaos
climatique devient irréversible et on
viendra sur ces enjeux climatiques et
sur la COP 27 qui se poursuit en Egypte
dans un instant autre sujet au cœur du
G20 Hélène qui lui se poursuit en
Indonésie les relations sino-américaines
ça a été bien sûr l'enjeu de la
rencontre hier entre Joe Biden
l'Américain et si Jane pin le Chinois et
les deux dirigeants tous souris font la
une ce matin du glombolt Times qui
précise que la rencontre a duré trois
heures et 12 minutes montrant main
suffisamment longtemps en tout cas pour
aborder les questions qui fâchent à
commencer par Taiwan dont l'indépendance
et la paix et la stabilité de la région
sont aussi inconciliables que l'eau et
le feu a prévenu le président chinois la
question de Taïwan jettent une ombre sur
les efforts de chez inping et Joe Biden
pour améliorer les relations
sino-américaines confirment de fin
lamental Times ce qui fait état
néanmoins de l'engagement de garder les
canaux de discussion ouverte sur cette
question la rencontre entre les deux
présidents qui inspirent aussi forcément
les dessinateurs de presse
serez-vous partant serait vous candidats
pour 2024 demande de chez inping est-ce
que je serai encore capable de marcher
en 2024 répond Biden dans le dessin de
peterbrooks pour de Times dans celui de
Christian Addams un président peut en
cacher un autre derrière chez inping se
tient le président russe Vladimir
Poutine dont les mains ensanglantés font
référence bien sûr à la guerre en
Ukraine la guerre que la Russie
maintenant en Ukraine on l'a entendu
dans le journal ça reste l'un des
principaux points à l'ordre du jour
officiel du G20 le franc courtois
des négociateurs de l'Union européenne
et les 19 principales puissances
économiques ce sont déjà mis d'accord
sur un projet de déclaration finale
commune une déclaration qui condamnerait
la guerre menée par la Russie en Ukraine
de son côté de gardien cet état d'une
rencontre hier en Turquie entre les
patrons des services de renseignement
russe et américains le quotidien
britannique indique toutefois que les
États-Unis assurent ne pas être engagés
dans des pour parler de paix secrets
avec Moscou en l'absence de
représentants
ukrainiens et puis quelques mots Hélène
pour terminer des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris de 2024 dont la
mascotte ou plutôt les mascottes ont été
dévoilées hier non sans suscité beaucoup
de commentaires mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter les frigides un duo de bonnet
phrygien rouge un basket au pied pour
l'une et prothèse à la jambe droite pour
celle des Jeux paralympiques drapeau
tricolore au coin les yeux pour toutes
les deux c'est de petites mascottes
représentent donc le bonnet phrygien
figure allégorique symbolique de la
République française les frigides qu'on
retrouve ce matin à l'asso de l'équipe
le quotidien sportif propose de vous
dévoiler ce matin les espoirs des
médailles des Bleus pour ces JO 2024
c'est très sympathique frige que
certains ont en effet spontanément
associé à tout autre chose que des
bonnets phrygiens observant qu'elle
ressemble davantage en réalité à des
clitoris avec le gland clitoridien
ressortant sur le haut et les corps
caverneux se pointant sur les côtés
comme deux petites ailes l'occasion
évidemment pour Libération commence en
privé de s'amuser de ces mascottes qui
en mettent forcément plein la vulve
et voilà merci beaucoup Hélène pour
toujours des transitions très aisées à
tout à l'heure dans Paris direct